where a lot of the uh your friends
family I know I saw some of the fans
were maybe a little worried that with
the situation that just happened at no
jumper that you your sobriety might have
been uh in question or or you might have
maybe gotten mentally hit by it did it
bother you in that way were you able to
kind of get through it the I was able to
get through it by the grace of God
however I will say the closest I've
gotten to relapsing the only time I was
like considering it really considering
it was after Adam kicked me out that day
and I I was driving around the valley
you feel me like driving around the
valley not stopping because I knew that
if I stopped I was going to go to a
liquor store and get on and get along
you got me a little bottle and get it
that day that day what was it that made
you what did you call you have a sponsor
I do have a sponsor and I call my
sponsor and like that was between him
that's dope and people that are close to
me they want to talk to me off the ledge
and I realized nah
that's not how I want to move but yeah
no it was really it got dark yeah dude I
mean I can only imagine because I I do
see like uh even just being on the show
the day because I I got hit up the day
um that all that happened we were at at
lunch
and uh because y'all can film the next
day right yeah the next morning yeah and
uh we're at lunch and Adam just hit me
he's like hey this is what happened
you're down to be a guest on the show
tomorrow just I just need to fill in I
was like yeah whatever I've been on the
show before I was like cool I got you
bro like Adam's always been super stand
up with me you know and uh
but then I really like didn't really
really realize like oh 80's about
because 80 called me and Eddie talked
and he was like dude I'm about to quit
right and I was like Jesus Christ like
what am I walking into and then everyone
assumed I'm like the permanent new guy
on the show right so well you had a dude
that is kind of like a New York version
of A.D correct you had like a lush one
of Jason's character correct it's like
oh look yeah you're white yeah okay he
was like oh look there's a white guy
with a fitted baseball right right yeah
so I think um I just and then I didn't
know about the Reddit thing and then I
went on Reddit and I was like oh
this is wild yeah it gets deep do you
regret diving into that part of it not
even for the result of what ended up
happening but just I do feel like I
could see how
going and looking in that toxic ass
thing and seeing everyone's opinion and
just kind of seeing all the negative
[__] that gets set in there could
probably like subconsciously [__] with
you
well here's the thing
yes is the short answer however
right before I wound up because you know
first me and disaster had the our own
podcast on no jumper oh no jump I
remember that yeah and it was cool and
we were just focusing on battle rap and
just Lyricist which is like the lane
that I'm in right another reason why you
and I are kind of similar we're both
hardcore hip hop Fanatics you feel me
like and um then they wound up bringing
me on the the main podcast on the no
jumper show and then people really took
to me and I wound up becoming a staple
over there or just one of them like at
one point in time I feel like anytime
I'd like to see a thumbnail you were on
it I was like yeah absolutely within the
past six months yeah I was on that
channel more than anybody else right 100
so what happened was right before I
wound up being brought on to the other
podcasts I would I'd hit a low in my
life and was very depressed going
through a lot of changes and um it was
just like down you know my my chicken
eyes split up right my mom was
terminally diagnosed with terminal
illness you know my company was going
through a lot of changes my battle rap
league so I just felt like really
unstable and you know I was like damn
you're suicidal I was suicide this is
prior to you and disaster doing this is
not this is or after after disaster and
I and before I got before you became
like a normal right right a regular so I
was super depressed I wound up going on
the show when I'm on there I'm like
they're probably not gonna [__] with me
like the crap the audience don't you
know I'm I'm older I'm not really in the
same vein is a lot of different people
they're probably not going to [__] with
me but then all of the comments were
like overwhelmingly positive right and
people start bombarding my Instagram and
like telling me to go to the Reddit and
all that and at that point I was so
depressed the only thing that was really
keeping me going was going and seeing
the positivity you were getting right
right at that time yeah yeah the Reddit
the YouTube comments the social media so
that really it wasn't for that I don't
know if I would have made it through
that dark period so I I'm grateful to
the Reddit for that right however I had
to I should have separated myself at a
certain point but it becomes you know my
addict's mentality it's literally like
chasing me I can see how that [__] is
addictive this validation is you know
sure for for an addict and even just the
even because you're a part of it and you
just want to probably just be like what
are these [__] saying about
right A B C or D look everybody over
there checked the Reddit whether they
want to admit it or not they like some
more than others but everybody is is
peeping the Reddit to some extent not
like I was I was actively posting on
there and then at a certain point when
the when these people in the Reddit saw
that I was going in there like oh they
start messaging you well we could get a
reaction out of him so then like and
then when the when the pendulum
inevitably swings to the other side from
that love to them not [__] with me
and dissecting me and you know what I
mean that right there I was trying
trying to win them over and it became
like this right vicious cycle yeah I can
only imagine man because like you know I
got a family I got kids and [__] I'm
like bro I would never want to be uh I
mean I feel like the type of [__] I do I
I purposely don't touch certain [__]
because I don't want to
like over expose myself I guess and my
kids and my girl and [__] so I even told
Adam when all this shit's been going on
the last few weeks I was like bro you
got some [__] thick skin brother
because
this [__] is crazy they would have been
on your ass if you had gone over there
permanently yeah
but even just like just see ing like you
know because I know Adam I could um
addressed whatever allegations over and
over so I'm like yo this [__] got
brought back up and I'm like bro here's
here's the thing and I want your opinion
on this yeah
I genuinely believe that if Adam had not
gone on that pod right when I was on
there and fired me in the very
unceremonious manner in which he did
a lot of that [__] wouldn't have
happened I agree and I think I might
have said something to that effect on
the podcast I think you might have yeah
I did I I did I did say something like
that I was like because because I I do
think that that moment was so viral
and it also highlighted
whatever
said issues that and I even told Adidas
when he was on here I was like you were
planning on leaving because there ain't
no way thick-skinned ass like A.D I know
got so mad about someone saying he has
four jokes that he quit like he was
planning this [__] you know but but
here's the thing A.D for show was and
I've been telling him he should leave I
told him and T rail like you guys should
be the [__] La drink Champs and they
and they got their own thing going it's
going really well for them here's the
thing
it kind of forced a.d's hand it did with
it being publicified and it was also a
nice opportunity if you were planning on
leaving already and those Wheels already
in motion it was a nice opportunity to
kind of take advantage of the of the you
know the virality of the moment and I
think it was Mutual I think that Adam
and no jumper was wanting to Pivot away
from that considering they are at a
certain point is a conflict of interest
when there's other podcasts with I don't
want to say regurgitating but utilizing
right the same content that you are and
getting more abuse for it I'd assume he
probably regrets firing you at the time
and like not to say that he shouldn't
have fired me but he could have easily
taken me outside no I think and I think
he he explained it to me like if you
catch some girl cheating on you and
she's at work and you're in the Next
Room if you caught your girl cheating on
you you're gonna be so [__] pissed
you're [__] going in then you're
[__] up her job like and I was like I
get it if like you guys had that
relationship and he truly felt like what
the [__] like
it was short-sighted and that is why
people should not ever make certain
decisions when they're emotional because
you always regret those decisions 100
but I do think that had he handled it a
little bit and I'm sure he would admit
the same thing but here's the thing like
to an extent
and that's when I was kind of going back
and forth in my head was well he's just
so mad and I know that was an element
but I honestly think that's capped to an
extent it might be because there was a
moment and the reason why I think that
he thought that he was gonna dunk on me
you feel me and everybody was just gonna
be like oh damn Adam just [__] marked
Lush out damn Lush is such a snake [__]
him right and they were going to be like
yeah Adam you're the man you look so
cool because if if he if this is
something he regretted then why did he
post it not only on the no collab post
that's the one thing the collab post is
crazy I think I said that at lunch
because because I think he said and my
boy uh arza showed me and I was like oh
he collabos this so not only the no
jumper fans are gonna see it but his
fans now has gotten millions of views
95 of the comments are on his helmet
like this is a dude that has stated
several times and this isn't a disc to
Adam at all right like you know
ultimately all this aside I do respect
him you know he said
everything is content
everything is fair game you know so I
believe he's like [__] it like oh firing
Lush that's one thing let's fire Lush on
on the air and then it wound up you know
kind of having an adverse effect that he
hadn't anticipated